next up tesla had an incredible q2
earnings report congratulations to the
tesla team
over a billion dollars in profit which
is up 10x year over year
from inside business tesla crushed its
q2 earnings reported revenue of 12
billion dollars with automotive revenue
of 10.2 billion of 28
from last quarter that's that's not year
over year that's from last quarter tesla
reported a net income
of 1.1 billion it's highest so far
uh tesla's q2 2020 profit was 129
million on about 6 billion of revenue so
1.7
percent margin so as you can see over
time in q2 of 2021
they made 1.1 billion on 12 billion
so 9.6 margin you'll probably continue
to see that happen
over time i would guess as they get
scale their operating margin more than
5x in 12 months
pretty incredible from the information
tesla is becoming a cash machine
so much so that musk is continuing to
ramp up capex levels while the company's
still producing free cash flow tesla
shares were up
1.5 after hours following a 2 rally
during
the day at this rate tesla shares still
down nearly 7 so far this year may soon
make up
the deficit for the year so back in july
uh tesla had reported they delivered 201
000 electric vehicles and produced 206
000 in q2
is just extraordinary so analysts
already had some indication
what revenue would be uh using sort of
back of the envelope
math their current capacity is 1.05
million vehicles a year spread between
california and shanghai
they are growing quickly obviously over
a multi-year horizon we expect to
achieve 50 percent
average animal growth and vehicle
deliveries in some years we may grow
faster which we expect to be the case in
2021 to achieve that tesla is building
factories
in texas and berlin uh obviously i think
the texas one is for the cyber truck
the core automotive business still
accounts for the bulk of tesla's revenue
but the energy business is growing from
techcrunch tesla on monday reported 801
million in revenue from its energy
generation storage business
which includes three main products solar
it's powerwell storage device and homes
and businesses
uh and its utility storage unit mega
pack i've been looking at this mega pack
because i was thinking about getting one
for the house
you could really like you can they're
big they're like
a bunch of power walls in one giant pack
uh and you're seeing office parks
and even little towns and cities put
them in revenue from this division grew
62 percent from the previous quarter
more than 116 from the same quarter in
2020
uh they don't break up solar versus
energy storage it's all the same thing
for them which makes sense
moreover the cost of revenue for its
solar and energy storage business was
781
of 781 million meaning that for the
first time the total cost of producing
and distributing these energy storage
products was lower
than the revenue generated
congratulations on that as well
tesla noted it owns about 1.3 billion in
digital currency that's interesting they
didn't say
bitcoin versus ethereum maybe they own
some ethereum two
3.5 percent of the company's automotive
revenue or 354
million came from regulatory credits uh
sold two more
polluting automakers that's lower than
uh at any other time in the last four
quarters so incredible
uh a quarter congratulations to the
tesla team they've worked really hard
and the proof is in the pudding the
product's incredible and people who own
tesla's
you know they they tend to buy more
teslas over time and the cars tend to
last forever
and this doesn't even take into account
i think the advances in self-driving
they're making
uh from my understanding the full
self-driving stuff that i'm seeing on
youtube and people who are in the beta
i'm not in the beta i haven't asked to
be in the beta
but people with the beta are really
starting to complete
you know more and more complex drives
without driver intervention
and it's growing really fast so if you
want to think about tesla
it's really an energy company the cars
are about one piece of that stack
your home having solar and having a
power pack
mean that your house is the new electric
part of the electrical grid and it's the
most important part it's like having a
well at your land
where you can pump up your own well
water and be independent of the grid
think how differently the world will
look during global warming
if we accomplish two tasks one we don't
have these centralized power lines
everywhere
that can get blown over and cause fires
that's why when we have wind
in california northern california
specifically they shut down the power
grid preemptively because they know
that sometimes a line will break because
the tree will fall on or just fly off
and that starts to fire and then you
have a wildfire so in
an abundance of caution they turn off
the power grid sometimes during high
wind
here and so if each home has its own
energy supply
and is energy independent that takes
more and more load off of the overall
grid
which means the grid is not going to be
under duress and you might be able to
sell
your energy to your neighbors and if
things go offline and
global warming etc we will have less
peak demand because your batteries will
kick in during the peak let's say a
really hot summer afternoon
if it's a hot summer afternoon and you
have your own battery pack
then you are not straining the grid when
the grid gets strained
then it has to do more fossil fuels so
most of the grids are set up to
if you hit peak load it starts burning
the coal so it does all clean energy and
renewables until such time
it needs to hit uh the dirty
uh you know fossil fuels is my
understanding
and so that obviously puts co2 into the
environment so we can
nip this in the bud just by getting rid
of the peak and smoothing it over
we should at some point just absolutely
take an infrastructure bill like this
like the next time we do infrastructure
or
we have a surplus in a place like
california we should just subsidize the
heck out of solar
to a ridiculous degree we should mandate
solar on every roof we should mandate
power walls or their their equivalent
doesn't have to come from towson come
from anywhere
but we should get more serious about it
um it's just a clear win
and obviously all cars should be evs you
know by 2030 or 2040. and we should
start retiring cars and taxing cars
to get them off the road uh and and stop
making them right and
this is where that tax credits i know
people it's a trigger issue for some
people
or a triggering issue why should a big
company that's doing so well
get those credits well they're getting
those credits because other companies
refuse to make evs
you need to have a carrot and a stick
the carrot is tesla getting rewarded for
making these incredible cars
and stopping the pollution of the
environment the stick is
volkswagen having the stick over their
head that they have to improve
their mileage and and their uh you know
what's coming out of the back of those
tailpipes emissions
and they actually lied about it and the
stick is what's pushed
even volkswagen into evs so carrots and
sticks
they kind of work and and taxation is
one of those things and the transference
of
uh capital from people who are burning
fossil fuels
to the people who are buying evs i think
entry-level evs we should uh make super
cheap give like a ten thousand dollar
tax credit on
you know fifty thousand dollar and under
uh cars
just get them on the road and all you
know city vehicles et cetera we should
just get off the ice engine i mean
it's time people we i mean it doesn't
take a genius to figure out
that cities are better to live in when
there's less pollution we saw it during
the pandemic when everybody was locked
down you could see the stars again
that's the future we all want right i
mean we have that future it's right
there we can just take it
and we can take it and create incentives
to to move people there quicker
okay oh and i'm gonna get a cyber truck
for sure
but i may get a land rover defender in
between like i'm gonna maybe lease one
for two or three years
because i need a car to go in the snow
uh like four wheel and uh
i wanna i wanna drive on beaches i don't
know why i feel like going for a drive
on the beaches or in the snow
so tell me which 4x4 to get if you have
any ideas
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company
let me guess way too much time well odoo
is here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow by bringing all of that
information
together plus odoo's integrations
eliminate
repetitive tasks and data entry if you
only need two or three apps to optimize
your workflow that's all you pay for
odoo won't stick you with the bill for
apps you don't use
odoo has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly in over 16
000 apps
from their active open source community
you can keep your books tight with their
financial software
and their sales and crm apps will help
provide a clear and organized view of
your business
so here is your call to action your
first app is free forever
and right now odoo is offering a 1 000
credit on your first implementation pack
that's not a joke that's a thousand
dollars
just go to odoo.com twist
to check it out that's odo.com
twist